welcome back to age 701 so in this video
we talk about
stability and the opposite of stability
the decays
of nuclei
okay so let's look at this diagram first
which shows the number of protons
the number of protons and the number of
neutrons here
and you find that the stable elements
sit in the so-called valley of stability
so there's a certain part
of our nuclei which are stable
this valley follows directly out of the
discussion of the binding energy where
you can calculate
the optimal z value such that
the mass is minimal it's about
a half in this area here at low masses
and about 40 percent of a
in the higher part time value
we already discussed that the binding
energy has
this form here with a maximum around
the mass of iron
here 50 some um
okay so it's energetically favorable
uh for some unstable nuclei
to just break apart in so-called fission
processes
and it's also energy addictive favorable
to fuse together
um to create energy
and we'll talk about the applications of
those processes
later on but for now we want to just
look at
radioactive radioactive nucleate
which can decay in various ways um
and so the the first most prominent
decays we're going to discuss here and
then we
will follow up a little later is it
alpha decay
which is splitting up
a mother particle splits up into a
daughter particle
nuclei and a helium which is an alpha
particle
or the emission of electrons positrons
or the capture of electrons as well
it is also possible but rather rare that
a nuclei just
spits out a proton or spits out a
neutron
so this is possible but it's rather rare
all right so let's look at the alpha
decay first as i said
we start from a rather large heavy
nuclei
and it seems possible for it to spit out
helium or an alpha particle
so the first thing we want to the view
we want to have here
is of the of the potential in which the
alpha particle sits
so the alpha particle sees a really deep
well
of the nuclear potential and it also
sees then
this boundary here this barrier
of the coulomb potential so for for the
alpha particle
to be emitted it needs to break through
this coulomb potential here
and you can calculate the likelihood
using quantum mechanics the quant
tunneling likelihood in order to figure
out
uh how stable an individual particle is
here i just wanted to show you something
um this plot here shows you
the lifetime of an unstable nuclei for
various
sorts as a function of the energy and
what you see here is this very strong
energy depend this is the logarithmic
plot
and what you see is the lifetime seems
to be rather rather short
when the emitted particle has a lot of
energy
and that can be explained by this plot
here very easily
in order for this particle the energy of
this particle when it goes here
is dependent on where this particle sits
in this potential
right so particles which sit at very
high values here
will have a low high likelihood
to tunnel through this barrier and
therefore a short lifetime
hence it has this particle has a lot of
energy
after it's being emitted so we see
lifetimes in the range of 10 to 10
nanoseconds to
10 to the 17 years for some example so
there's a huge variation
depending on where the other particle
sits in this potential
you can have a discussion of the
energetics involved and we use our very
same
formula for the binding energy um so
you write this down here including your
your alpha part your helium here
um and then you know just figuring out
what are the contribution of the
individual terms and
since we observe experimentally alpha
decays only for heavy particle in this
discussion here we can assume
that z is approximately 0.41
times the mass number and so the energy
of the emitted
alpha particle for this to be able to
occur
is has to be positive and so we find
this to be possible for a values
starting from about 150 experimentally
we observe
this to start happening at about 200.
all right the next thought we want to
discuss is better decay so this is shown
in this diagram here
where you know starting from carbon 14
decays for example carbon 14
you will see this in the next recitation
is a very useful probe in order to date
uh
living things and date when when they
were not living anymore and we will
discuss
why and how you can actually do this
but you know for now carbon 14 can decay
be a better decay and what you find
is nitrogen an anti-electron and an
electron
this is a better decay or better minus
decay
and using our particle physics
discussion
we can easily understand this but
neutron
is transformed into a proton
via electro weak processes with a w the
electron comes out the anti-neutrino
comes out
and similarly we can look at carbon 10
here into a boron with a neutrino and a
positron and again here
we have a w plus in the decay
so now we can again use our binding
energy in order to understand this
so what we want to do here
for constant mass numbers
you want to plot the binding energy for
the individual
atoms or nuclei
and so if you do this for odd a
right those is where the the pairing
term doesn't contribute
you find this nice quadratic term
and you can you know find better decays
in each of those instances here for a
even we have the question whether or not
z is odd or n is odd
ah sorry z and n are odd or z and n are
even
so you have two quadratic functions here
and you find the better decay between
one and the other
and so that's interesting you find those
the case chains um
based on where you start in the chain
you have possibility to go back
and forth and because of the ease and
odd pattern
um the lifetime of the decay
can vary quite tremendously between this
individual
individual states last but not least
electron capture if you have a
a very massive nuclei an atom and the
electrons
you know thinking about a cloud around
this some of the electrons can come very
very close
and be captured um as
into the nuclear eye and you find this
here the
time direction goes goes up proton
captures via the weak interaction the
electron becomes a neutron and emits
an arduino and an example is the
electron capture of krypton into
borion all right so we
start to get some sort of understanding
of nuclear decays
um we find this value of stability here
we find in a large range ranged
for lower numbers of z um
better decays for higher numbers of z
find
better plus decays and for very heavy
nuclei we find alpha decays
proton decays
are seen at the very boundary here
and nuclear fission processes where they
where the
nuclei spontaneously breaks up we
haven't discussed in detail but you can
think about them
very similar the to the alpha decay
as you already kind of probably saw from
the discussion of the better decay
it's possible to have rather long decay
chains so you start from
a radioactive nuclear eye which then
decays and decays and decays and decays
in those kind of chains so this is you
know two examples here the thorium
chain and the uranium chain creating
all kinds of other new elements um
and on the uranium chain it's very
interesting to say uranium
you know is part of our core if you
build a house and you build co
if you build um the foundation this
concrete you probably have some uranium
in there
which then in this decay chain generates
radium
and therefore if you build a house with
a concrete you want to have a measure to
get rid of the radium which is just
floating around
all right so this is it for for now uh
we continue the discussion with more
detailed understanding or detailed
discussion on
how those decay processes are possible
and what we can learn from them
you